[Music]
the Kardashians they're not movie stars
athletes or musicians but they're more
famous than most celebrity so what makes
them famous and how are they able to
cash that fame in I sat down with the
three sisters and I asked them to
explain what they really do have a lot
of fans but you also have haters some
say that you were just born into this
situation and a Fame and success that
you don't have talent I've heard that
and you don't have to work hard tell
America what is your talent what do you
do when people do say that you know
having a brand like this as we've gotten
lucky and stuff like that I mean I think
that this doesn't come easy you know we
we work really hard and if it was easy
then three sisters really go as everyone
can do it and so what does it involve
every day I mean I think what people
forget is before our TV shows we had
clothing stores we've always been in
love with the fashion industry Kimberly
was a stylist I would assist her at
times we do any had her own clothing
line before this we did closet
organizations that was actually a
business and then we opened up a kid's
store as well as - or women's store and
then I think just the platform of having
the reality show has given us a bigger
platform to be able to design and create
this brand for ourselves but our goals
have always been really fashion based so
even if you hadn't had the show you
probably would have ventured into this
business well we were already in this
yeah we were already in this mess I
think the show because really now you're
a new kind of celebrity you've innovated
this idea that you don't have to be
playing basketball you don't have to be
singing it's your persona that drives
your brand do you think that that helped
your lining absolutely I mean the show
is our platform the show is our best
commercial the show is we we show
everything from our creative process to
the finished product on our show without
being visible on TV
I don't think we would have you know
been able to spread this far you know
gotten this far with our clothes with
whatever we wanted to do in life
whatever our goals were and our this
elevates it to a different level for
sure okay so you have the mind how do
you make sure that you're here in five
years well our it's not about if the
shows are here in five years our passion
you know before the TV shows war our
stores and our passion for fashion and
after the TV shows that's still going to
be our passion but I think and to make
products that's why we're so involved in
the design process in making sure the
fit is right on every item right I heard
that you came in at the last minute and
said I don't like the fit mm-hmm and one
of you it was her jeans yeah well
because I'm like no that's not the right
way they're supposed to hug a woman's
body I'll say scratch that we're not
doing it we're not going to trust me we
could have done this years ago just put
our name on something and giving it to
the masses but that's not us before
these shows after these shows we're
always going to be in love with fashion
so we have to put our heart and soul
into something and they have to
represent us and we do that and you each
have your own thick special fit for
women in our denim we each have our own
fit I love wearing skinny jeans so my
fit is this skinny jean and I'm
definitely a petite girl normally not
when I'm pregnant but I think you can
see our personalities not just in our
denim but throughout the entire line
like the dress I'm wearing now is you
know I like my Styles a little bit
sexier so we have you know just
different pieces you can tell if you
know our personalities you can see what
pieces in the collection people say that
though that's a Kim P so that's a quart
because we all design it together we'll
have to agree right oh really okay yeah
no we definitely there's pieces that Kim
and Chloe are like oh those shorts
there's a Whitney short we don't like
that I'm like no but that's the blessing
about having the Kardashian Kollection
it's one brand with three designers
that's being pregnant
led you to think about clothing for
pregnant women I've been thinking about
clothing for pregnant women and then
clothing for children
I live on home design blogs and just
like I'm obsessed with it and now my
obsession is nursery design and so I
think that that's organic for us so just
you know we like to do stuff that we
love and are passionate about you're
also doing a lot of tweeting mm-hmm
incredible joy to Twitter platform you
how many Twitter fancy you have I think
almost 15 million okay what about you
seven million okay six million okay so
you're tweeting all of your designs or
you pick special well we what what we
always say to is that we love to listen
to what people are looking for from us
to when we do that a lot through Twitter
a focus group
yeah okay you can basically have a free
focus group but we we really listen and
we take that advice I mean even when I
was designing my fragrance I wanted that
couldn't decide between two colors to
make my bottle of my perfume and I
tweeted out the to pick the pictures and
I got I really went with the response
that I got so not only is it a good
focus group but it also we involved the
fans in our product they feel like they
helped create this helped design it and
I think that's the case with our jewelry
our our home Betty and everything that
we do and that is another reason why we
wanted we've you know always like we
said earlier wanted to design clothes
but we we definitely waited for a
company such as Sears that has a great
price point but will not want to control
our design process and will not want to
control our manufacturing process
everything is because we are in the
retail business we know how much things
cost we know what it takes and we really
thought to have a company that believed
in us let us design how we want to but
also kept it at at an affordable price
point there so there is an ideal price
point that you want to be yeah yeah we
absolutely yeah I mean and I think we
learned that through having our own
clothing stores we started off with a
really higher price point and
then we had the TV show and our fans
couldn't afford that price point so we
had to readjust and figure out what our
fan base of the people that would not
you mention there's a recession I mean
we wanted to be accessible to the you
know artists Samantha and also our
tourists that are mostly that she's
older than she is pregnancies I do
forgive me I'm not only I'm not very
sharp either sir but we you know we
wanted to be just in our store with the
economy and the way things were going
Khloe and I used to be the ones in her
stores every day ringing people up so
you know we would see what people would
ask for ring people up dance yeah wonder
stare each other and Kim was very heavy
into her styling then and she was a part
of - for sure but Kourtney and I we were
the sole employees for like four years
didn't have one employee we did the
housekeeping we did our own taxes we did
every we would not do was no business
yeah we wouldn't give it up to one
person we are learning credit-card debt
because everything was on her crutch she
had a credit card someone gave her a 50
thousand dollar limit and we'll put all
the clothes on to it and we were in debt
but hey that's how you start a business
he's always had these issues with mom
but I feel like then it was fine and
then chancer legs bringing us all up
again your persona is so much a part of
what you do and it's really amazing been
able to get well and that's a question
is that good I mean that's hard because
you have to open your lives so much but
I think it's who we are and it defines
us and our I think even the clothes that
we wear define us and the you know the
way you decorate your house defines you
the the lingerie that you have so all
this is because everything's always
constantly changing like in our lives
and your mood changes and everyone has
different sides of their personality for
you to be able to keep up with the
trends like sometimes you like something
and it's just so expensive you have to
go with something more simple but with
our line it's so affordable that you can
see your personality in the line and
change and grow with the trends with us
so will you ever be able to step back
and just let the line sell itself
absolutely that's our goal I think
that's every you know but I did some yes
so without we would never like we are
too controlled like we would never put
our name on something without but if you
decide you don't want to do the show
anymore without doing the show yes yeah
we have to tie up in the design process
every step of the way I met like be able
to take a real vacation and you know
trust in our things I'm good at like
setting boundaries of our I think we're
great at setting like our priorities and
our values that they are you know to
have a clothing line in a brand such as
Sears is astronomical does we never
thought that could happen and we never
believed that that we just thought we
were gonna be in our store - we just
thought that so for this thing else and
that would be I am doing this those days
- but that I think is we're so
appreciative and we're so in awe and
we're we can't even like so when we go
to our appearances like wait get nervous
and think no one's gonna show up we're
like please and we pray before we do
and I was like we just hope that people
are going to show up and when they come
in they're wearing our clothes and we're
just like it's mind boggling that people
are like this well maybe that's the key
to your success you're never complacent
right you can't be well I want to thank
the Kardashian sisters for giving me
this interview and we are going to
continue to watch you as your business
grows make sure that you come back and
let me know about all the things you're
doing yeah thanks for having us and with
the Kardashians I'm Lee Hawkins see you
next time
[Music]